local now Governor Joe Lombardo
preparing to deliver his first state of
the state in just about one hour from
now good evening to you thank you for
joining us at five I'm Brian Loftus I'm
Denise Valdez eight news now
investigator David charns is live for us
in Carson City with what we can expect
to hear tonight David
yeah Brian Denise we have made it now
inside the assembly here in the Nevada
legislature in the legislature here
where behind me the governor will be
giving his State of the State address
live to everybody in this room plus
everybody at home now let me tell you
why this is such a big deal why we've
been talking about it for the last
couple of weeks this is basically a
fresh State for the governor a fresh
slate for everybody in this building
having a new governor and many new
lawmakers have just sworn in the past
couple of weeks it's also a chance for
the governor to lay out his legislative
agenda remember there is just a
four-month window every two years when
things get done in this building
Republican state senator Heidi ganzer
talked to me earlier about what she
thinks this means for that process
we've been out of whack really for the
last four years because we've had one
party dominating
the legislative process and I think it's
really important that other people's
voices are heard and that we develop
better policy with a balanced
legislature and again a check on the
system through the governor
and you can see people filling in right
now into the Assembly Building where
both the state senators and assembly
will be sitting as long along with the
governor's family and a lot of guests
this room will be packed after the
speech we expect to hear from the top
Democrats in this building of course the
Senate Majority Leader and then the
speaker who resides in this room
Democrats have a super majority in the
assembly meaning it will take a lot of
compromise to get things done this
session things expected to get kicked
off around six o'clock and of course
we'll bring that to you live inside the
Nevada legislature I'm David charns 8
News Now